as far as you guys know I'm a big fan of
the Dark Knight in Batman Begins and
I've been following the Dark Knight
Rises very closely and I like the
trailer a lot and you know I thought was
perfect because the teaser for the Dark
Knight was just a symbol with dialogue I
mean you got nothing and this one we
actually got footage from the film and a
shot of Batman in Bane and you know
that's a lot compared to the Dark Knight
teaser they recently released some new
photos of the dark knight fighting Bane
in front of what looks like possibly
some form of a jailbreak and I'm not
entirely sure what's going on in the
photo because obviously we have no idea
now it's not much of a spoiler to say
that Batman fights Bane in the movie
because obviously that's gonna happen I
mean it has to happen that's like the
whole thing with Bane and Batman he's
the only villain who is ever able to
really physically intimidate Batman to
the point of him being frightened and
that's something I really like because I
was thinking about Batman Begins in the
Dark Knight Batman has never been scared
of one of the villains the whole thing
of Batman Begins was him overcoming fear
of bats and what happened to him as a
child and everything but the end of film
you know he stands right up to Ra's al
Ghul you know he's like he's stoked he's
there he's like a physical match for
Ra's al Ghul and the Dark Knight he was
never actually scared of the Joker
physically or being harmed by the Joker
the Joker just challenged him in mental
ways and psychological ways he
challenged Batman's rules and the way he
governed over Gotham City and so he was
sort of a psychological opponent
Batman's never been frightened by an
opponent I find that so cool because I
just I just sat down and I thought about
it wow this is gonna be the first time
we're gonna see Batman like dude
crap before am I going to do and I kind
of geeked out for a second thinking
about that because I realized that
Batman's never actually been challenged
physically and we're finally going to be
able to see that so these photos show
Batman and him fighting and they're
surprisingly very good set photos and
this photo in particular I really like
the look that Bale has here that look is
telling me that that might even be one
of the first moments where he's like oh
shoot Bane can fight so yeah I'm totally
geeking out over that
and they also had an image of the Batpod
which is pretty cool also a lot of
people were talking about this shot at
the end of the trailer you see someone
standing behind that man a lot of people
like who is this guy and it's like
Christopher Nolan knew that we were all
gonna do that it's like he's just saying
like mmm yes we should add in that shot
because it's very cool but all of the
Batmen nerds will be asking who that is
and I am the greatest filmmaker alive
here's my take on what I think it is in
the trailer you hear Gordon talking
about how Batman needs to come back then
obviously we were I'm assuming that's
because at the end of The Dark Knight
Batman takes the fall for all the bad
things that happens and I'm assuming
that Gotham City is going to hate Batman
at the start of this film I'm thinking
that Batman is going to be the only
person in Gotham City who stands up to
Bane and the whole city is going to be
watching and Batman will win over Gotham
through that that's that's just what I
think that Batman the Gotham is gonna
have to look and say shoot Batman's
awesome more than likely I'm wrong
because Christopher Nolan always
surprises me and that would be
absolutely fine with me so yeah those
are some news in the Dark Knight Rises
I'm about to go see you springing up the
change-up I'll have my review for that
when I get back hope you guys enjoy it
and have a good day